hey everybody and welcome to community
canyon
this is a joint planner coaster project
organized by coaster connection and
coaster bots
and featuring outside of these guys and
myself also loken
and digital dan the way that this works
is that we have one park file and we
each get the file for a little bit
and our own area to work on and what
you're seeing at the moment
is some of the stuff that the others
have built because as it happens
i'm actually the person who's lost to
work on this and
after my turn it should all be finished
up
now i also have to say getting this
episode out
um has been a little bit of a rocky
journey
partly because of poor planning on my
part
it happens that during my week of being
able to work on this
i had already planned a trip to paris
for almost the entire week
so that was a bit unfortunate and then
i've also had some technical issues with
planet coaster and my computer
that just made this a lot harder if you
see some time-lapse
lag spikes and yes they even happen in
the time-lapse that's how bad it was
then that's just my computer acting up
despite the fact that this is sped up 12
times sometimes the game just completely
froze for a while or went down to 5
fps inexplicably i'm not sure
it made working on this a little bit
hard and i'm mostly just hoping that the
time lapse doesn't look too bad as a
result of it
anyway let's actually talk about the
coaster because
this thing is really interesting and
honestly i am really glad that somehow
they pushed me into trying this
um this kind of concept or even coming
up with it because
really i was mostly inspired by what
digital dan
had done before me because he created a
swinging mind train coaster but did
something completely unique with its
namely actually taking the track and
inverting it
going through light to fly elements as
if it were
a fleet a freefly or 4d coaster
which is really cool because with the
way that the
swinging cards work they will stay
upright so even though the coaster goes
through inversions
the cardstone actually inverts all the
time but it also does do a trick where
they actually go upside down
either way it's really cool it's like a
really extreme sns freefly coaster
and it mostly inspired me to try and
take one of the in-game coaster types
and do something completely different
with it
to try and come up with a new kind of
coaster type that doesn't really exist
in real life
so besides that another major
inspiration for me for this coaster as
some of you guys may have guessed if
you're a really big coaster nerd
is vertigo in walibi belgium now
vertigo was a very infamous coaster
i should say that only existed for a few
years and is regarded as one of the
biggest failures
in roller coaster history not
necessarily because it was a bad
experience per se from what i've heard
it was actually a really fun coaster
and if i'm looking at povs and off right
footage
it actually looks really good basically
the way that the coaster worked
was it was a massive suspended coaster
that was suspended on big supports
and crossed huge stretches of space
without
additional supports next to it and it's
almost like a hybrid between a cable car
and a roller coaster in the way that it
flew between these different supports
which is also very fitting
because the coaster was manufactured not
by a roller coaster manufacturer but
by doppelmeyer which is an austrian
cable car manufacturer
and as it happens actually the well
de facto market leader in cable car
technology
it's a company that has bought up many
influential cable car companies
throughout the years
such as garaventa and vonroe where
vonroe i think is actually quite known
because many of their cable cars are
actually some of the original cable cars
that you find in theme parks across the
world
many old cable cars from disney parks
for instance in the us
uh and things like that so it's a
company with a history that goes back
way back and um it's even very much
linked
to theme parks the new disney skyliner
that was built
in um disney's disney world
is also a duffel meyer cable car but
yeah i'm getting a little bit off topic
anyway doppelmeyer developed vertigo
in wally b belgium as a kind of
prototype roller coaster
that's really somewhere between a cable
car and a roller coaster
and although it was a fun experience and
it got pretty good reviews
it always had lots of technical issues
was broken down a lot
and in the end after a few years it was
decided by the pike to just remove it
instead
and i think walibi belgium you know took
quite a while to recover from that
because
if you go back into their history for
quite some time around that they didn't
really do any major investments
and the park kind of stalled and really
only in the last couple of years have
they started to recover from that
if i can go off topic a little bit again
i do have to say that i really like the
direction that they're taking i went
there last year
and i think it's turning into quite a
beautiful park
it's a really good family park as
opposed to wallaby holland which is a
lot more
thrill-based and less good-looking i
would say
walibi belgium actually has some pretty
charming theming
and some damn good dark rides so yeah
it's a cool park but unfortunately uh
vertigo didn't really turn out to be the
success that they had hoped
although i do respect their courage
in trying something completely new
because that coaster was
really unlike anything anybody had ever
seen and i'm not sure if we're ever
going to see another coaster like it
again
but for what it's worth i wanted to try
doing something similar
in planet coaster and so
the way that vertigo was laid out was
very much influenced by the way that it
was supported
as a really a suspended suspended
coaster
um it had this big towering steel
structure with helixes around it
and between that long stretches of
straight track
that kind of flew down like a flying fox
um so that was that was interesting it
almost looked like a zip line
the way that it moved between these
giant structures
and so i figured what if we take the
in-game suspended coaster
and put it on these kinds of supports
instead
which notably is a bit heavier
quite a bit heavier than the uh the much
more cable car like
uh zipline s coaster that doppelmeyer
had built
but i'm not an engineer and
i don't know how well this could work in
real life but
the idea for this coaster was really
just to take a suspended coaster and
suspend it off of these kind of
supports and make it look structurally
sound enough
and honestly i think it even kind of
works
with the layout of this coaster because
the helix
nature of how these supports work means
that you get
lots of spaces between these towers
where you really swing from one curve
into the other and because the cars are
swinging
um it gives a really good swing on that
as bend
and some really interesting transitions
between the curves
so i'm a big fan of that and also
i think it just looks kind of cool which
brings me to another reason why i was
inspired to build this
i was actually having a discussion with
coasterbot on twitter recently
on a post by cupcakes and coasters about
whether coaster treks break immersion
and the the whole thread in general i
forgot the
you know the the exact topic of it uh
but it was generally about how we
have these theme parks with very densely
themed areas and very
immersive environments um but then
roller coaster trek and roller coaster
mechanics can kind of break this
and so very often highly themed theme
parks try to
hide their roller coaster parts as much
as they can
but it's still something that can kind
of break the immersion
and i think it would be really cool to
see roller coasters that are
uh really themed to what that trek are
or that
somehow incorporate that track into the
theme
um i know that at the time cupcakes and
coasters position on the whole matter
was that it wouldn't be necessary and it
doesn't really matter
but personally i just think it would be
really cool like a new
creative avenue for the roller coasters
imagineering uh to see how the design of
the roller coasters themselves could be
featured
into a design of a whole themed area
which i think is not too ridiculous of
an idea i think there's one roller
coaster type which does this in real
life which is the mine train coaster
which obviously it's themed after a mine
train but not just that the track
itself looks like you know train rails
of course it's a little bit different
but i think it's the case where the
track of the roller coaster itself is
the most
immersive and there are still a lot of
hidden parts to it as well
i know that disneyland for instance
tries to hide the locations of their
block breaks as much as possible
i highly recommend checking out el toro
ryan's
newest video on black what big thunder
mountain which is
a really cool you know in-depth look
into
exactly how big thunder mountain works
that kind of reveals all of the behind
the scenes stuff and reveals just how
much behind the scenes there is there's
still a lot that's hidden with these
kinds of coasters
but the parts that you do see of the
coaster and that you really just
have to see because it's what you're
riding and um
it's it's all the mechanical stuff that
has to be visible all of that is very
much
themed and so for me at least it's a
ride type that's more
immersive than other coaster types
because when you're
when you're flying with a b m flying
coaster through
some kind of rocky terrain like in in a
happy valley park in china
you have these beautiful environments
and just awesome
settings but you can still see all of
the b m track around you the steel
supports that
create this machine and you know it's
it's something that you can't really get
around very easily but it still breaks
the immersion a little bit
compared to a mine train where you can
really imagine that you're on this wild
train
ride and all of the track that you see
is roller coaster track but it's also
part of this
immersive idea that you're on a wild
train ride
so i think it's really cool and
an idea that could be played with more
now the challenge is of course
what kind of coasters can you actually
incorporate into certain themes
at the time my idea was that in a
steampunk theme for instance and
honestly i think steampunk is the kind
of theme where
you can go you can go the most crazy
with roller coaster tracks and make it a
believable kind of contraption within
the narrative
of the of the themed area um but
i was basically thinking of some kind of
suspended transportation system
a little bit inspired by the city in
bioshock
or by something that my friend jazz made
in city skylines recently where he had
some floating cities
and suspended monorails in between them
as a transport method
suspended coasters could really fulfill
this kind of steampunk
you know futuristic travel
machinery role which is of course a
little bit ridiculous
but within that whole suspense of
disbelief i think it's
very much a setting where the coaster
design itself can be part of the theming
so for this i'm not going quite that far
and really building a floating steampunk
city but
in line with the steampunk theme that
digital dan has created for his area
just before me and next next to me on
the map
as well as the mind theme that was
established at the start of this map
i am kind of going for this so
my idea for this and yeah just
just hold on to my uh to my thoughts
because i'm gonna
go a little bit off topic on this i
guess but my idea was
uh cable cars are a transport
technology that's very much linked to
mines as well
in fact arguably the first cable car
that ever existed which was
in gdansk in poland around the 17th
century i believe
was actually built for a very similar
function it was built to transport
soil to some part of the city that was
being expanded
and while at the time this cable car
used ropes
and horses to power the whole thing
which makes it a lot less efficient than
today's cable cars
it's the first time that massive amounts
of rope
were hauled onto supports and dragged
material to one place
from one place to another and it's still
something that happens with a lot of
mines
actually uh doppelmeyer still creates
ropeway technology to transport goods in
mines
and excavation sites and some other
companies do as well it's
it's something that's still very
relevant and
yeah i figured it would fit the the mind
theme
that this this whole area is very
vaguely alluding to
and also in line with that i would have
to say that i'm starting to work
on the station here and stuff is kind of
going slow because the menus aren't
really being as friendly as i'd like
them to be and there's a lot of testing
you know what kind of pieces
i am using so this is some stuff that
i'm really gonna have to upgrade my pc
for because this is
not gonna be very doable in the long run
um but yeah i'm just
gonna deal with it here um but i was
really inspired by a particular mine
in belgium which is called winterslach
which has a beautiful hallway with
ironworks supports holding up this
triangular roof
and lots of brickwork and decorations on
the side
um so very vaguely inspired by that i'm
building the station building here
really not going too much into detail
here um keeping everything quite
simple um in part because
well i wanted to finish this whole
venture
in a timely manner um but still try to
use as much of the kind of
flemish revival aesthetic
that i could see which is not per se
the aesthetic of the mine it's a little
bit more fancy than
um mine buildings were although there
are some very
fancy mine buildings um but i just
really like flemish revival it's a
really cool
kind of renaissance revival style that
you find all throughout belgium
and you find some very similar styles in
the netherlands as well
features lots of intricate masonry and
cornerstones and i just love it
lots of different colors um it's it's a
style that was really popular
around the end of the 19th century and i
know in the netherlands a similar style
was led by pierre calpers and led to
buildings like the national museum
at the reich museum and also the
amsterdam central station which are very
similar buildings but you can really see
these sorts of elements of the style in
there as well
and of course what helps is that the
winter slug building
as a as an industrial mine building is
very open space
that has no supports in the middle which
kind of makes it perfect for a coaster
station i'm really just taking
all of my ideas from there here and
creating a similar kind of
big iron garden girder structure to hold
up the roof
and create this large space underneath
it where the station can sit
especially because suspended coasters do
need quite a bit of space for this
station as well
with the only caveats that the station
is a bit too long
at the time when i was building the
station i still had eight cars
on the train i later brought this down
to five cars
partly because eight cars felt too heavy
for the support structure
even though i'm not an engineer and the
support structure is probably not that
on point anyway
um i felt that eight cars really would
be asking too much
of the suspended track here but also i
simply didn't have space for a larger
transfer table
at the end of the ride so something had
to give i didn't want the transfer table
to realistically be able to actually
transfer trains in and out so that i
could run two trains
so i'm going with two trains of five
cars instead
which in any case is much better than a
single train of eight cars
but yeah it's probably not the very best
situation
for throughput anyway but yeah
keeping this station very simple and not
really adding too much to it
it's just a rectangle with two entrances
uh one on the front one on the back with
the the exit path actually being on the
back which is
maybe not the most practical solution
because that is where the most
amount of space is to create a cue path
i just always like to have my entrance
on the front because it very clearly
demarcates where the entrance is at and
then also have the
actual you know path into the the queue
somewhere in that area as well so that
it's kind of clear where you have to go
if you want to enter this coaster
and the front is a little bit more
detailed than the back
but there's not too much to it some
simple spires but i'm not going
overboard here
and creating my own spires like i
sometimes like to do as well
now skipping forward a little bit and
yes
i made a bunch of cuts in these time
lapses just to make everything
a little bit more sped up because i'm
trying to fit it all into a single video
um but yeah going forward a little bit i
am working on a small building just to
house some of the
the horrible cattle pens that are going
on in this queue here
please ignore what a terrible cue this
is normally i'm always a man of very
themed cues and
i hate boring cues honestly i think it's
something that
theme parks in general should put more
attention towards
i mean you really are spending most of
your time in a theme park especially on
a busy day
standing in queues or walking from one
attraction to the next one
so put some effort into it but yeah i'm
going against my own mentors here and
just making this a very simple
switchback building
uh with a kind of industrial route those
sawtooth kind of roofs
not too much going on it's very simple
but i think in the layout of this whole
area it just kind of works
and i had to fit that cue in somewhere
might as well do it over here because
well i couldn't really come up with
anything that would be much better
in a perfect world i would love to do
like
more of a barren 1898 queue with maybe
even
a bigger connected building uh going
through
some kind of garden beforehand but
i didn't really have the time to try any
of those
more advanced ideas so i'm keeping this
one very simple
and just trying to go as much as i can
with the kind of
industrial slash mind theme that was
established beforehand
um so yeah not too much going on here so
let me actually
skip forward to something else that was
happening later on
um i decided to build a little lake over
here
and well i think it's something that
at least gives you some interesting
shots because at this point i was really
just
building in a way that i figured would
look cool for
the final cinematic footage don't hate
me for this please
it's just something that you gotta do
sometimes i was just really thinking
about how the coaster would look off
right and figured
hey a pond over here might be really
cool also added this lake
on the other side of the layout which is
really to get some good
camera angles honestly i think it's fine
sometimes to build in ways that you know
you're already picking some camera
angles
and thinking of them and trying to build
around that as well it's something that
i do a lot
it's something that i don't really admit
to or talk about a lot
but still i often build in a way that i
think would work out for a video
and you know it's not something that can
be really bad
as long as you're trying to stick to
some realistic layouts as well
but sometimes it's good to try and set
up some shots because otherwise
you know you build your things and then
it's just a complete
uh surprise what it's going to look like
and especially from the vantage points
of parts
you should always i think check it out
as much as you can
while you're building stuff see what it
looks like and see how it all comes
together
and based on that either keep going with
it or try to change the composition
of it a little bit uh just so you're not
really surprised
about what the coaster looks like once
you're actually down there
and looking from an actual perspective
at it
rather than just the aerial perspective
which you're normally
looking at it from when you're actually
building it
now for all of the foliage around here
i'm really keeping it very simple adding
some
very basic rock work and some bushes
here and there
um but nothing too out of the ordinary i
would say
in the middle i couldn't really think of
what i wanted to do specifically
but i just knew that i wanted to keep
this space very open because
i like the fact that you know on the
suspended sections of trek
you're spending a lot of time in the air
without any supports
and especially if you have any parts you
know directly underneath that you get
that interesting interaction where
from the coaster you're flying over
these parts which is cool and when
you're standing on the paths you can see
the coaster directly above you
i i'm not sure if this is enough
distance
uh of a clearance to like require
coaster nets
i decided not to install any coaster
nets because i figured it was high
enough
uh up there which kind of doesn't make
sense because if any objects do fall out
they're just gonna
go faster but then again
how do you stop that at these heights
but yeah i just didn't want to
actually add any coaster nets because
they would totally ruin the look of this
whole area and the openness of the space
not to mention that i do think that
these are very difficult cars to throw
things
out of in real life of course you always
want to make sure that when a coaster
comes close to paths you want to make
sure that
any kind of loose items falling out
don't accidentally hit on somebody's
head because if you get hit with a phone
in your head that travels at 100
kilometers an hour
it's probably gonna be very lethal or
super damaging at the very least
um but with these kinds of very enclosed
cars that the suspended coaster has
i think it's fine i'm not even entirely
sure why i'm going on about this so much
people probably wouldn't have noticed if
i hadn't talked about it
um but yeah it still irks me a little
bit that there aren't any coaster nets
i just really wanted the space between
these giant
pillars to remain as free as possible to
really give you that feeling
how the the coasters are flying over
these suspended tracks
from basically every vantage point
and then for all of the foliage around
it i'm also trying to mix
a little bit with the foliage that the
surrounding
areas uh have so
just taking some trees from some of
their stuff
and filling it in with some oaks this
honestly
is very similar to how i would always
use the fill in the maps
on coaster college
which i i also try to do the very fast
and easy way just creating these tree
lines by sinking a bunch of trees into
the ground
and covering it up with different
species of trees as well
there's really not too much to it but i
think especially from a distance it
works well enough to make it feel as
though
you actually are somewhere in a forest
and in a real life location
rather than just a random sandbox
in planet coaster i do think it's
interesting though that
we're on this you know red sand western
style map but everybody decided to
change the color of the ground to grass
maybe it's just because
that red sand just doesn't really work
for most themes except for western
but it's something that was just kind of
striking
and finally for this final stretch i'm
just embellishing the area with some
extra scenery
even though it's not really themed i
still wanted to add some fountains and
some basic gardening and everything
but really the the focus of this whole
build
is just on the coaster itself so
not going to end it in detail here just
trying to make sure that no area stays
untouched
and doesn't like totally bring you out
of the immersion of the whole area
but there's something that i do want to
show before i
move on to the cinematic footage and the
pov
which is one other thing that i actually
built
beyond just the simple gardens which is
a flat ride i eventually ended up
choosing to build a troika here
because i think it works out the best to
actually preserve the view of this
and i'll be totally honest i built this
whole thing because i think it would
look cool
there's not really any other purpose to
this flat ride other than just
working in the general layout of this
area
and providing a really cool shot but
honestly i think it worked out in the
end
and it's just something that i wanted to
feature because all of the other areas
in the park do have at least multiple
rides
or you know some kind of flat ride focus
as well which of course i'll just say as
a reminder you can find in the playlist
as well
but really for my purpose all of the
focus is on the coaster itself and this
is just something that
helps provide a little something extra
and
one cool shots that i had in mind
actually for the video
um also i just noticed again one of
these like spikes
for anybody who is you know really
concerned about this
and about the comments about it i know i
need to fix up my computer but at this
point
it's more of a time thing than it is a
money thing because
i am able to afford an upgrade i just
really need to
like find the time to get into it and at
the moment my whole life is a bit
uncertain and kind of wonky and
i really don't have the time to look
into this kind of thing
another problem is that planet coaster
is the only game which is especially
problematic
with planet 2 of course koali zoo is a
lost cause
but um park attack still runs okay and i
can
still play city skylines so i don't know
what's up with planet coaster but it's
just running especially terribly
and eventually i only got it to work
decently
through nvidia geforce but
whatever the case it's something that
you shouldn't be too
um concerned about i think it'll be fine
that sounds totally like something
somebody would say who knows that
things aren't fine but no by that i mean
i'm gonna look into it at some point in
the future but right now
there are too many other things that i
need to worry about
anyway that's not something that i want
to bore you with
let's get down to the the final section
of this video
um so i can actually show you the
cinematic footage and the pov
so after building this little
fountain thingy here it's finally time
to
show you what the right looks like so
with that all said i hope you enjoyed
this video
and um i'll see you in the next video
whatever that may be
[Music]
so
[Music]
you